euh le
temps
presse les prophéties disent que l'hiver fimble mène
à la
guerre de ragnarok arrive
mon histoire ne finit pas de me cacher dans ces
bois
je devrais être là-bas pour découvrir qui je
suis qui est loki
je ne te permettrai pas de te battre
avec dieu
je ne veux combattre personne
je veux juste des réponses
et si ces réponses mènent à la guerre avec
asgard
peut-être que c'est ce que mère a gagné
tu ne sais pas quelle mère regarde
bien
je reconnais cette expression de faiseur
partout où
odin a des tours dans sa manche nous
n'avons pas  osé
se demander s'il y avait quelqu'un qui pourrait
nous aider,
vous voulez dire ici
l'ancien dieu de la guerre dans ces terres qui est
bien mort pour un homme mort qui ne semblait pas
très désireux de voir qu'il n'a pas été appelé
s'il est là-bas
nous  je dois le trouver
venir dans
ce que tous les fils sont arrivés
nous essayons d'arrêter ragnarok pour aider les
gens
et si la seule façon de le faire est la
guerre la
guerre n'est pas la seule façon d'
arrêter de penser comme un père pendant un moment
et de commencer à penser comme  un général
tu as l'air d'un cal  m et personne raisonnable
es-tu une personne calme et raisonnable
[Musique]
dans les moments de crise la
panique ne la
maîtrise pas
[Musique]
laisse-la te servir
ici tu viens avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu auras ta réponse bien assez tôt
bien certains d'entre eux